l'arnaque incroyable que je vais vous
raconter aujourd'hui peut paraître comme
étant une arnaque sentimentale mais
c'est bien plus que ça elle va s'appuyer
sur les sentiments sur l'espoir mais
aussi sur une forme de crédulité et à
l'époque en 1962 on n' pas les moyens
d'aujourd'hui c'était très efficace vous
allez le voir c'est le moment de la
collaboration commerciale oui cette
vidéo est sponsorisée par ODU Odou c'est
un logiciel tout en un qui offre un
éventail d'application pour les
entrepreneurs et les PME gestion
relation client vente marketing gestion
rage comptabilité inventaire et plus
encore bref Odou c'est une solution modu
qui vous permet une facilité de gestion
en fonction de vos besoins etodou
propose également une application
d'édition de site web afin de permettre
à tout le monde de créer un site web
moderne en quelques clics petite
précision le tout gratuitement parce que
la première application est offerte à
vie la plateforme est très simple
d'utilisation il suffit de drag and drop
des blocs ensuite il ne vous reste plus
qu'à personnaliser votre site en
modifiant le texte les couleurs les
images et cetera la grille permet une
mise en page très intuitive des éléments
de votre page Web vous déplacez
facilement le texte ou les images afin
d'harmoniser un petit peu tout ça en
plus quoi de mieux que de pouvoir
rajouter des formes ou des animations
pour dynamiser un site en quelques clics
c'est rapide c'est simple et c'est même
joli si vous voulez en savoir plus sur
la création de sititees web avec Odou
mais aussi sur les autres services qu'il
propose je vous mets le lien directement
dans la description attaquons notre
histoire je vais prendre le point de vue
d'une personne de l'une des victimes qui
s'appelle Jean-Louis Jean-Louis il est
célibataire il rêve de rencontrer
l'amour et à cette époque ça se fait
beaucoup de passer des petites annonces
dans les journaux et même des journaux
matrimoniaux spécialisés dans le domaine
mais avant de passer son annonce
Jean-Louis va acheter ce genre de
journaux il va vouloir s'en inspirer
pour voir comment les autres écrivent
leur annonce parce qu'en plus on paye au
mot c'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup
d'abréviations qui sont utilisé et en
détaillant un peu la mécanique en
essayant de comprendre comment passer la
meilleure annonce possible il en
découvre une qui va particulièrement lui
plaire l'annonce de Caroline 22 ans elle
habite en Martinique elle dit qu'elle a
pour projet professionnel de devenir
mannequin et qu'elle recherche un homme
ayant le même goût qu'elle qui aurait
entre 25 et 30 ans ça tombe bien c'est
le cas Jean-Louis alors Jean-Louis
change son fusil d'épaule il n'écrira
pas d'annonce il prend sa plus belle
plie et il écrit une magnifique let à
Caroline il lui envoie direction la
Martinique avec une photo de lui
évidemment quelques temps plus tard le
temps qu'il faut à l'époque pour que son
courrier arrive en Martinie que Caroline
réponde et que le courrier arrive
jusqu'à Jean-Louis Jean-Louis découvre
dans sa boîte au lettre une lettre avec
un tampon celui de la Martinique il
ouvre la lettre c'est Caroline qui lui
écrit Caroline Ligier explique-t-elle
elle lui explique qu'elle a reçu
beaucoup beaucoup de courriers bien plus
qu'elle n'aurait espéré recevoir mais de
tous les courriers il y en a un qui est
sorti du spontanément c'est sa lettre à
lui la lettre de Jean-Louis et elle le
remercie pour la photo en retour
elle-même met une photo c'est elle en
bikini elle est un sourire ravageur elle
est magnifique blonde aux yeux bleus
dans son maillot de bain Jean-Louis est
séduit il est littéralement sous charme
et il va commencer à entamer une
correspondance avec elle ils vont
s'écrire le plus souvent possible
c'estàd que dès qu'une lettre arrive
l'autre se précipite pour répondre et
ils vont communiquer comme ça pendant un
petit peu plus de 2 mois parce que les
choses vont très très vite c'est à ce
moment-là où Jean-Louis lui dit mais
viens en France marions-nous en France
tu pourras t'épanouir et avancer dans ta
carrière de de mannequin professionnel
et enfin on sera réuni un mariage alors
qu'ils ne se sont jamais rencontrés mais
la folie de l'amour leur fait paraître
tout cela crédible et Caroline aussi est
enchantée de cette nouvelle et accepte
le mariage il y a juste une nombre au
tableau Caroline du fond de sa
Martinique n'a pas les moyens de se
payer un billet pour venir jusqu'à Paris
à l'époque ça coûte 500 francs c'est une
petite fortune aujourd'hui Jean-Louis ne
roule pas sur l'or il a pas les moyens
de débourser de sortir comme ça 500
francs pour les envoyer à Caroline alors
il va en parler à ses amis il va en
parler à sa famille il va vendre des
petits objets et il va réussir à réunir
ce petit pactol de 500 francs et à
l'envoyer à Caroline Caroline lui répond
quelques temps plus tard l'ultime lettre
celle qui annonce son arrivée fin
décembre par paquebo où elle arrivera au
port du Havre il a le jour il a l'heure
il sait où est-ce qu'il doit l'attendre
tout est parfait et nous sommes
maintenant fin décembre et on retrouve
Jean-Louis il est sur le qu du port du
Havre il est très bien bien apprêté il a
mis son plus beau costume et il a dans
sa poche une photo la photo de Caroline
en bikini parce qu'il veut être sûr de
la reconnaître après tout il a juste une
seule image d'elle cette image en 2D
qu'il a sur cette photo qu'il a reçu au
tout début ils sont nombreux évidemment
à attendre sur le quai hein tout le
monde attend des amis l'être aimé la
famille et le Bagbo arrive la foule
monte sur le pont descend du bateau
Jean-Louis scrut observe regarde il
attend la jeune femme tarde un petit peu
à apparaître peut-être qu'elle laisse
passer un peu le Brouis pour pour être
sûr de reconnaître Jean-Louis en se
disant si la plupart des passagers et
des personnes qui attendaient sont parti
on va se retrouver plus facilement donc
Jean-Louis attend patiemment il comprend
un petit peu cette mécanique les
dernières personnes arrivent et toujours
pas de Caroline plus personne ne descend
du bateau mais Jean-Louis est pas
complètement inquiet parce qu'il reste
encore quand même une cinquantaine de
personnes qui attendent un passager
alors peut-être le temps de réunir des
affaires peut-être se sont-ils perdu à
bord du bateau ou simplement aux
toilettes en tout cas ils sont encore
nombreux à attendre mais le temps passe
et Jean-Louis décide de lever un petit
peu son inquiétude il stresse un peu il
a besoin de discuter alors il demande à
un monsieur qui à côté de lui qui a à
peu près son âge d'ailleurs et qui
inspire confiance parce qu'il est très
bien habillé il lui demande s'il attend
quelqu'un lui aussi et le monsieur lui
dit oui oui vous inquiétez pas tout le
monde doit pas être descendu parce que
moi aussi j'attends une personne et il
discuteent tous les deux et puis ce
fameux monsieur lui dit qu'il attend une
jeune femme une jeune femme qui va
rencontrer pour la première fois il sort
une photo pour lui faire voir cette
cette jeune femme c'est la même photo
que celle de Jean-Louis celle de
Caroline Jean-Louis reste bougeb il
arrive pas à dire grand-chose il tremble
un petit peu il comprend que ça ne va
pas il arrive juste à sortir la photo et
et et à la montré au jeune homme qui
attendait avec lui et le jeune homme
crie très fort Caroline quand je vous
dis qu'il le crie très fort il le crie
assez fort en tout cas pour que les
autres personnes qui attendent sur le
quai tous des hommes entendent Caroline
et soi interloqué ils sont tous
d'ailleurs très bien habillés et au fur
et à mesure ils se rapprochent tous et
tous ont une photo de Caroline Ligier la
même photo ils sont au total 50 à
attendre Caroline Ligier sur le quai
vous pensez sûrement avoir compris la
fin de l'histoire cette arnaque mais ça
va plus loin que ça les 50 hommes qui
attendent sur le quai vont au
commissariat et sont reçus par
l'inspecteur du Havre l'inpecteur du
Havre qui se retrouve quand même avec 50
personnes en costard toute la même photo
à la main en disant cette jeune femme
nous a arnaqué on l'attend sur le cas
elle est jamais venu à qu'on lui a
envoyé 500 francs il la traite
d'arnaqueuse il la traite d'escrot il
donne à l'inspecteur le nom et le prénom
de Caroline ainsi que son adresse à fort
de-fance pour l'inspecteur du HAV c'est
une affaire de routine ça va être très
simple à régler il décroche son
téléphone il appelle le commissariat de
fort- de-fance où il arrive à voir son
collègue malgré le décalage horaire il
lui communique le nom le prénom
l'adresse de Caroline il raccroche en se
disant que l'inspecteur de fort-
de-fance va aller à cette adresse et
l'histoire sera pliée l'inspecteur de
fort- de-fance se rend à l'appartement
de Caroline Ligier il arrive là-bas
ouvre la porte regarde les noms sur les
boîes aux lettres commence à faire une
enquête de routine et il trouve le nom
de Caroline liégier mais sur l'étiquette
il y a deux noms Caroline liégier et un
certain Benjamin il s'étonne un petit
peu il va frapper à la porte personne ne
répond il descend voir le concierge et
demande s'il a vu les habitants de cet
appartement le concierge répond les
habitants je ne sais pas il y a bien un
homme qui passe comme ça de temps en
temps alors l'inspecteur lui demande si
ça fait longtemps qu'il l'a vu et le
concierge répond ah ben là on ne le
verra plus de toute manière puisqu'il a
posé congé de son appartement
apparemment il veut rentrer sur Paris
l'inspecteur de fort- de- France
recontacte l'inspecteur du port du Havre
il lui fait le rapport sur ce qui vient
de se passer l'inspecteur du port du
Havre commence à se dire de toute
manière si cette fameuse Caroline Ligier
est vraiment mannequin professionnel je
devrais trouver des traces d'elle dans
les agences ou peut-être dans les
annuires professionnelles de la haute
couture il commence à chercher et bingo
y trouve il trouve le nom de Caroline
Ligier sa photo et même son adresse donc
il s'y rend l'inspecteur se rend à
l'appartement de Caroline il monte les
escaliers frappe à la porte elle ouvre
c'est bien elle c'est sûr en voyant sa
tête il y a pas de doute possible
d'ailleurs elle répond au nom de
Caroline liégier il commence
immédiatement à lui parler de Fort de-
France et elle est très appeurée très
surprise de voir les policiers débarquer
chez elle et a dit ben je ne vais
j'allais pas me forcer à épouser
quelqu'un que je n'aimais pas cette
réponse ne satisfait pas l'inspecteur du
H qui lui demande où est son complice
Benjamin Caroline ne comprend pas le mot
complice mais elle sait qui est Benjamin
et elle dit ce c'est pas mon complice
c'est tout l'inverse un an auparavant
Caroline avait passé une annonce dans un
magazine matrimonie qui était édité en
Martinique elle avait reçu beaucoup de
réponses elle avait été séduite par une
lettre la lettre d'un fameux Benjamin et
ils avaient entamé tous les deux une
relation comme ça à distance uniquement
à l'écrit pendant environ 2 mois puis
Benjamin lui avait proposé de venir la
rejoindre en Martinique mais elle avait
pas les moyens alors Benjamin avait
récolté 500 francs lui avait envoyé elle
était venue en Martinique et était resté
une quinzaine de jours là-bas mais il ne
s'était pas plu il ne s'était pas PL
avec Benjamin avait pas accroché ni
physiquement ni mentalement à cette
personne mais on fait pas un tel voyage
surtout à cette époque pour rester 48h
donc elle était restée de semaines
là-bas et où logait-elle à l'appartement
de Benjamin qui se trouve bien à
l'adresse à laquelle s'est rendu
l'inspecteur de fort- de- France quand
elle elle est repartie fin de l'histoire
plus jamais eu de nouvelles de Benjamin
seulement voilà lui dit l'inspecteur du
port du Havre et ces 50 hommes qui
attendaient sur le quai et les 50 photos
elle ne sait rien de tout ça la seule
chose qu'elle sait c'est que la photo
que lui présente l'inspecteur c'est bien
la photo qu'elle avait envoyé à l'époque
à Benjamin l'histoire finalement est
relativement simple il y a forte à pari
que Benjamin ce jeune martiniqué quand
il a eu l'annonce à l'époque il a
répondu à Caroline et reçu la photo et
que la photo lui est tapée dans l'œil
que ça a fait son petit effet de là il
se serait ruiné pour payer un billet à
Caroline pour qu'elle viennent le
rejoindre c'est ce qui s'est passé une
fois sur place elle a passé 15 jours
Martinique elle est repartie elle a
repoussé ses avances et là elle a dû se
sentir flouer peut-être même a-t-il
estimé qu'il avait été victime d'un abus
de confiance ce qui est possible ça
reste pour moi dans le spectre des
possibles parce que c'est une
explication relativement viable au fait
que son annonce elle l' passé uniquement
son annonce matrimoniale dans des
journaux martiniqués elle avait pas du
tout fait la même démarche en France
alors pourquoi là-bas peut-être pour
avoir un billet pour passer des vacances
à l'œil le fait est que Benjamin ne
s'est pas arrêté là du coup il aurait
fait une cinquantaine de copies de la
photo qu'il avait et s'est dit je vais
me faire passer pour Caroline en
publiant ce coupci l'annonce en France
et peut-être je vais trouver quelques
crédules qui ser serit comme moi aussi
bête pour payer un billet et m'enrichir
sur ce compte là la finalité c'est que
Benjamin n'a jamais été retrouvé il a
quand même empoché 25000 francs de
personnes qui rêvaent de rencontrer la
jeune femme sûrement est-il parti de
Martinique et sûrement que ce pécule là
lui a permis de se mettre à l'abri
est-ce qu'il aait voulu se venger est-ce
que ça lui a donné l'idée de faire cette
arnaque le fait d'avoir le sentiment de
se faire arnaquer on saura jamais et
c'est sûrement un mélange des deux
d'arnaque de bluff et pas de diamant
arnaque bluff et diamant c'est autre
chose c'est un jeu de société que je
viens de sortir il y a 5 jours j'en ai
parlé sur la chaîne Youtube vous avez un
lien dans la description si vous voulez
voir ça c'est un jeu de deux à quat
joueurs où vous allez incarner des
escroc des des malfaiteurs qui se font
un concours comme ça d'arnaque et vous
allez essayer soit de faire la meilleure
arnaque soit de faire tomber les autres
participant en envoyant un peu la police
sur leur trousse je suis très très
heureux ça fait un an et demi qu'on
travaillait dessus et qu'on qu'on jouait
au bureau il existe enfin pour de vrai
n'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo qu'il
présente il se trouve bah dans toutes
les librairies des magasins de jeux
j'espère que cette histoire en hommage à
Belmar elle vous a plu merci à Odou le
partenaire de cette vidéo d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo en partenariat
commercial prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt Ciao